So now that we know what locality is,
let's see how do we use it
to improve data accesses.
First, we will look at an example
that considers borrowing
books from the library.
In this example, the library represents
a data repository that is large.
So a lot of data there.
But, it is very slow to access.
We need to go there,
find the book in the building, check
it out, bring it back home, and so on.
When we're borrowing
books from the library,
typically there is a lot
of temporal locality to it.
For example, if we are a student, we
might need to look up the definition of
locality very often,
while we're studying.
And usually also, there is a lot of
spatial locality to using books.
For example, if we look up some
computer architecture definition once,
we are likely to be looking up other
computer architecture stuff too,
in the near future.
So continuing our library based
locality and data access example,
we have seen that the library's large
but very slow to access and that
accesses to information in the library
have temporal and spatial locality.
So when a student needs a piece
of information from the library,
what should he do?
Should he go to the library,
find the information, read it and
then just go back home?
Should he borrow the book,
take it home so
that future accesses to the information
in the book are much faster?
Or should he take all the books and
then build a library at home?
Let's consider each of
these three options.
If we go to the library every
time we need something,
we're wasting a lot of time.
Finding the books, and then looking
up only one piece of information, and
then returning the book because we
know that there is both temporal and
spatial locality, which means we will
be probably reading the same book, and
nearby books, very often.
So, the problem with this approach is
that it does not benefit from locality,
and this is why typically, people do not
use it when they need to study a topic,
and use library resources.
If we go the library and
borrow the book, we bring it home, and
now we have the book on the topic that
we're currently working on close to us.
So this is an approach that does exploit
temporal and spatial locality and
eliminates the problem of the library
being large and slow because we have
very few books borrowed at home so we
can quickly find what we need in them.
This is why most people
will use this option.
The approach of taking all the books and
building a library at home is very
expensive and
also provides very little benefit.
Yes, it saves us the trip to the library
and back, but it doesn't save us
the time of searching among many books,
finding them on the shelves, and so on.
So really, we'd rather have relatively
few books that we're currently
interested in, than have many book and
have to look them up very slowly.
So just like people when faced with
these choices about the library
usually choose the second option
because it's a good trade off
between being able to find information
quickly and not being overwhelmed with
a quantity of information that we have
brought in, when we have a processor
that needs to access main memory
we will use the same approach.
Instead of going to memory for
every single memory location,
we will bring the content of memory
locations that we are interested in
closer to us, but we will try
not to bring too much close to
us because that will result in
a very slow structure close to us.
So, we will, again, have slow accesses.
So what you want is something small that
keeps only the information we are really
interested in, and that small repository
of information is called a cache,
when we're talking
about memory accesses.